this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by raycon babble green chef
and mint mobile more on that later let's
get into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it
in the night pants studios i'm ryan
sickler ryan sickler.com ryan sickler on
all social media
i can't thank you guys enough thank you
thank you for the support thank you for
everything you're doing to help this
show grow i really do appreciate it i
love my [ __ ] job and i love you all
all right i want to tell you about some
tour dates night pants nation tour is
getting underway guys
uh hitting it in the fall basically so
september 16th through the 18th i'm in
phoenix all right september 30th through
october 2nd i'm in
indianapolis y'all coming to indy um
i'm in vegas with tom segura october 8th
and 9th and october 28th i'm headlining
the bray improv out here in braea
california
uh go to ryansickler.com you'll see all
the tour dates there
sign up for the email list you'll be on
there to know about everything the
honeydew podcast is the
website for the show and please
subscribe to the youtube i get asked so
many times how you can help it's free
it means nothing to you hit subscribe
means everything to me that's all you
got to do you're watching it
just subscribe to it all right the
patreon show it's five bucks a month
it's the honeydew with y'all i'm doing
the same show that i do with all of our
guests
but with you all if you or someone you
know has that story that has to be heard
submit it to honeydewpodcast
gmail.com we'll go through them we'll
get you on we've had
so many amazing stories i can't tell you
they keep coming in we're just i'm not
going anywhere and i'm not dogging and
i'm not doing half hour shows i'm doing
hour plus shows with every single one of
y'all
and it's five bucks a month all right
and for five bucks
you get the entire back catalog and you
get this show the honeydew
ad-free a day early at no additional
cost all right it's five bucks a month
if you sign up for a year
you get over a month free it's a pretty
damn good deal so
jump on it and uh join that community
over there all right
also you guys know about these d1
athletes now they can get paid they can
get sponsored
we don't want d1 athletes we're the
honeydew i want d2s i want jucos we
already got two on board okay we've got
uh caden wood kaden wood my man's a d2
pitcher at seton hill don't confuse that
with seton hall
seton hill all right and they went to
the college world series this year
i got marcus everett who's a fisherman
but he's a bow fisherman this dude the
fish don't stand a chance
i'm looking for athletes give me you got
to be good though don't come at me with
some [ __ ]
give me a bowler give me a dart thrower
who's
is there a [ __ ] cornhole champion
where are you give me some goddamn
what's it
frisbee uh frisbee golf i'll get one of
you guys i'm sponsoring
let's go submit your [ __ ] uh request
at honeydewpodcast gmail.com just put
honeydew athlete
in your subject and let's see if we
can't rock you some gear and get out
there and
and support to do all right now that's
all the [ __ ] to get out of the way
you know what we do here we highlight
the lowlights i always say these are the
stories behind the storytellers today's
storyteller
very excited to have here first time on
the honeydew ladies and gentlemen please
welcome sam morrow y'all welcome to the
honey thank you man
thank you for being here thanks for
having me yeah this is long overdue dude
you're one of the new york guys i've
been wanting to get on here for a while
thank you man mark norman told me to
reach out i was like i should do ryan's
thing yeah so mark is mark's done it a
couple times
yeah we learned on here that mark norman
lost his virginity
to a hooker but who was older than his
own mom
wow that's kind of he that he really he
was like
i've never thought about it i was like
bro you lost your virginity to a woman
older than your mom he's like i did yeah
a prostitute
he's got grandma issues and that's crazy
you like expired milk and [ __ ] damn
all right before we get into uh
highlighting your lowlights
plug promote everything you want well
i'm on the road every week you can get
those dates at uh samurail.com
show so i think this month uh lexington
kentucky kansas city missouri uh
portland oregon
and uh royal oak michigan then the next
month it's like
philly boston st louis all over but yeah
i got the pot with norman the drinking
podcast we might be drunk
basketball pod pod don't lie and i got a
couple specials on youtube
got great specials on youtube thank you
man yeah and you did it yourself
yeah i mean it's it's the only way to go
and i mean you ula guys figured out the
podcasting
how to make it look nice we got off zoom
like two weeks ago in new york
but uh you know you know this is like
legit
production value and and uh yeah you
just
i got sick of just waiting for people to
be like we
some of those bigger networks or
streamers they're like we're gonna take
five months to review and then say no
and i'm like i don't have
all i have is time you know so you you
can you can reject me but don't don't
suck my time do it now i also i don't
want to get too precious about material
i like to just burn it so
if someone steals a bit i'm not like
heartbroken i'm like yeah whatever i
dump that joke anyway you know
so i just want to keep putting stuff out
there well i love your [ __ ] and i love
seeing people do it like that because
you know we talk about it
the last whatever year more 15 months
these people weren't working yeah these
agents
these managers these everybody a lot of
vacation photos i see
a lot of vacation photos i got a salary
i've got a 401k a lot of them got
firearms a lot a lot of agents did get
fired
but yeah and then guess what yeah what
were they doing then
they weren't working but guess who kept
rolling right along comics kept putting
out content
because now you can now you got this
[ __ ] it's not i don't know why we
keep calling them phones these are
goddamn computers in our pockets but you
can do anything you want now from a
phone
craziness i mean yeah anything you want
you don't need any of that like it all
shifted and anyone that's not on anyone
that's thinking 2019
it's a [ __ ] rap dave chappelle
went out to a cornfield
yeah and made a show and people came you
don't need that
it doesn't need that story inspiring to
me because he's already got like
what 40 million in the bank but a guy
that could go
madison square garden for sure a guy
that could go for staple center
or [ __ ] staples what am i talking about
he could go sell out sofi
probably it's cool that chappelle is
such a purist that he's like i'll do it
anywhere
that's right you know but uh but showed
that you can yeah and that people will
go there
there was not one person like man i'm
not going to see that if it's not at the
garden
right i'm not going to see that if it's
not at this club they were like i'm
going to see dave [ __ ] chappelle
well that's that's what we realized
during the pandemic right people will go
anywhere
like how many nights can you watch
queen's gambit before you're like i'm
good
i got it you know like i want so i was
doing shows in like
the east river amphitheater like yeah
rooftops
parking lots and that supernova show
here i was telling you i really think
like
there's gonna be rules and things like i
love the early morning hours for senior
citizens and grocery stores i think that
[ __ ] should stay
for sure you know i think the delivery
of alcohol from restaurants now should
i want your [ __ ] margarita that
should stay that's cool yeah
and and there's a couple shows that are
gonna make it i think and that supernova
show is
[ __ ] one of the best shows in this
city good outdoor shows
if they if there's if they stay they
earned it because no one wants to do
outdoor shows at this point
people are asking me like come do my
back alley uh
i'm like that was a pandemic thing dude
i'm not now with indoor options i don't
want to do
but the roofs too it's like those were
kind of special to do just because they
were like private
and they felt like almost like
prohibition style like comedies elite
they're people lighting joints who are
like we're like is this okay i'm like
dude none of this is legal
we're not supposed to be on a roof none
of this is okay you know
so i mean i i loved it i i i
i loved it i never want to do it again
but i loved it
so um let's talk what's your did you
sell
did you say your social media you said
you're watching which is my name yeah
samurail but how do you spell your name
because i always want to put an extra l
on it it's two r's one l right yep
all right um makes no sense phonetically
it's it's one of those annoying things
where my dad's like it's morel
not moral oh see i said immoral i don't
give a [ __ ] but he cares
and that made me be like should i like i
might feel like but that's his name so i
guess i know
but let's talk about your dad sure
because it looks like all we left was a
good segue
no this is my this is my technically my
stepdad okay okay
now my biological my name growing up was
uh
my mom's name's greenberg okay so that
was that and then uh
my biological dad's last name was elgort
say it again elgort elgord
yeah all right i like morale way better
yeah elgor's you know it's fine
so tell me about your biological dad
well i didn't meet him
uh so how do you your parents were they
married when they had you or
were did they just they weren't married
okay it was the young kids or
i haven't asked the whole story because
i feel like it'll upset my mom
you know i don't can't make her cry
through that to tell you
i actually have a bit about this now
that i've been working on where it's
like
the idea of it was like when you're
whenever you tell someone that you were
like an unplanned you know a mistake
they're like i was unplanned or broken
condom and i'm like i've never
i've never broke [ __ ] with my mom
because i love her like i can't i can't
imagine putting my mom aside like mom
real quick uh did you get raw dogged or
what like what happened hey did that
come with you on purpose
or was it an accident i know i ruined
our relationship but my friend gary
wants to know
uh so you know
certain things i haven't asked in detail
because i think would upset her but uh
what do you think probably casually
dating and
and would be my guest but i don't want
to and she got pregnant
yeah and he was like now he i have
a little more empathy no he wasn't there
no i never met him
until much later in my life i was
probably 19 when i met him but
wow all right so he uh
so yeah no he was gone he
had lost his wife i think not too uh
long ago to cancer before they started i
see
so i think he was like i can't do a kid
right now i just
he already had a kid oh i haven't met
him i haven't met the
uh you know yeah
so you have a half brother yeah that he
had already i think he lives out here
that would be a great surprise if you
just had we have we have a special guest
i believe is right
but uh no i never met him but uh i
brought it up to my biological dad once
i was kind of like oh maybe it'd be cool
to meet him he's like yeah you know i
put that out there and he didn't seem
interested
all right it's like never mind saw your
last spec
on that roof not for me not for me
but uh it's weird he looks a little like
me which is he's much older he's like
he's probably like 20 years older than
me oh wow or maybe like my biological
dad's old he's like in his mid 80s so
oh [ __ ] oh he had me i was like yeah so
how old was he when he had you
50s 50s yeah how was your mom
40 or 41. oh so she's an older mother i
think that's what i was i'm the only one
i'm the only biological uh yeah it's
like
uh and then my dad who raised me was
like i called dad i love him he's like
legally
he's a lawyer so he's like i want to
make this official like in a courtroom
and legally adopt you
and he's a great dad you know he's uh he
really is it's like
all right so let's go back for a sec so
you're raised by a single mom then for a
few years yeah for a few years that's a
long time though when you're just one
parent with a baby especially a newborn
yeah yeah and then she meets your
stepdad yeah they got set up on a blind
date for real
yeah yeah and my dad is he's funny he
said to her on the phone he said
i have a bit of a receding hairline just
like a bit and then they met and he's
completely bald
so it's pretty good
uh he's a funny guy and then
uh you know he has two kids of his own
who my stepbrother and step-sister we
just
go brother or sister we don't we don't
play those right so you're all close
then
yeah i don't see my sister a ton because
she works so much i i feel like i text
with my brother more
you know but uh i'm gone every week
she's gonna say do they ever like fly
out to a close gig
and kick it with you for the weekend no
and that's some [ __ ] my cousin's trying
my sister's got it now because he wants
to get away
really he goes hey i'm gonna just tell
my wife it's research like if you're in
atlanta or something i'll fly down on a
southwest flight from baltimore for 70
bucks can i just kick it with you in
atlanta for i was like [ __ ] yeah
if he wanted to do that i'd rather do
that than hang out with some
strangers she's got three kids she's
never sleeps she's like you know got a
high pressure job
my brother i could see that would be
good like going that's like sideways too
they're going through the divorce type
situation
you know but on a road game it's kind of
got that fun vibe right
dude i love uh yeah i would love that
all right so step dad comes in great
he's a great dad
right away he takes to you and you take
to him and yeah i was so young i just
was like i remember him
i remember us writing the name because i
was sam greenberg up until then and he
was like well you're going to take my
name now that i'm marrying your mom
and i was like okay i remember him i
couldn't get morel right you know i was
just like writing it and he's like
close not right and then uh you know
so yeah we yeah it was pretty instant
that we just kind of became a family you
know so when you're saying dad out here
you refer
right ahead i say biological dad for
the other one so you never took his you
never had his name you were your mom's
greenberg and then yeah well i mean it
would be crazy if i took that's a
painful reminder right there if i just
but i uh yeah i'd say biological dad
before him i used to have a bit about
this or i'd say my biological dad
um people were like was he a good dad
and i was like if he were i probably
wouldn't refer to him as my biological
dad that's anyone i have to put that out
damn i think he knocked it out of the
park if that's how i'm introducing them
to people
you know
but uh no but so as you're growing up
when do you start to question or want to
know or be interested about
biology i'll tell you i was satisfied
with my dad i love my dad so i think i
wasn't
really curious until i dated a girl who
had two
psychiatrists or parents which good
if you're if you were a psychiatrist and
you marry another psychiatrist
just don't have kids it's you're gonna
[ __ ] them up
she she would pull this move we were
like 19 and fight she would just pull
this move or she'd be like
who are you really yelling at oh no and
i'd be like that's [ __ ]
you yeah what do you think
[Music]
yeah so uh she would pull that move in
fights a lot and i
and it got to a point i was like i guess
i gotta meet him so i brought it up to
my mom they would they encouraged this
is that what it was she heard she well
she it was just how they raised her to
be very like
this is your parent you have issues with
your parents that's why you're
mad at me not that it was like it would
take away anything that she
did you know any responsibility for her
action so
i remember i asked my mom i was like
well i'd like to just meet him i'm just
curious
and uh she said all right well why don't
you he left you a safety deposit box
like a note
in the bank he left a note for you which
is like it's like what is this [ __ ]
it's like a movie no i she was weird
when i brought it up and i understand
why
and meanwhile my dad who raised me is
just like go for it like he just knew he
was like
not a great dad it was like i heard a
story once that uh
brad pitt was dating uh i see yeah
good brad pitt was dating jennifer
aniston and i think ashton kutcher is
like can i just take her on a date and
he was like
go ahead that was the vibe of my dad
meeting my you know he's like
you're not gonna win you know so i met
him
and uh i called him and i was like hey
and he's like hey
no real quick had your mom had any
contact with him
during these years nothing okay no i
mean he never reached out to meet you
or okay all right um which is [ __ ]
weird
it is when you're so cause you're not
that's two decades you don't even
wonder well yeah it's weird that i
didn't i think i'm not you i mean him
i was holding a lot in i remember i saw
a therapist i went to tulane for like a
year and a half in new orleans i
remember i saw
a therapist there it was so weird it
looked like dude it was katrina had just
hit
so the it was like a flooded hospital
where i saw this therapist it looked
like
it looked like shutter island it was the
weirdest [ __ ] i've ever seen
you know i but my mom's like this is the
therapist you're gonna see so i was like
all right
you know it's kind of like a you know i
acted out a lot uh
so i remember i saw this therapist and
he was like roasty that's the only way
to
like he was kind of a dick he was really
smart and a good therapist
but he would like zing you like i
remember i was like yes i was given my
background i was like well there's a few
years it was just me and my mom and he
goes you and mommy against the world and
i was like what the [ __ ]
like what's your problem like what that
is
weird i was like i know i picked rickles
to go through my [ __ ]
but let's take a quick break and tell
you about our first sponsor raycon
no matter how you're feeling about
getting back out there there's no
denying it's an adjustment and when the
world gets too loud something i love to
do is create my own soundtrack
by popping in my raycon wireless earbuds
sometimes you need some
upbeat music to pump you up before you
see people or to stay calm
with some guy meditation or stay calm
with some people you're about to see
so let me tell you right now ray cons
are the best way to listen they come
with a bunch of gel tips for your
comfort
and unlike some of the other brands they
don't stick out of your ears
all right i use them all the time i
travel with them listen to music when i
walk
exercise everything i love it and i do
do that
i put music in and then i see videos to
it my head i like really make a
soundtrack to that stuff
and raycons have a 32 hour battery life
so you can listen to what you want when
you want for a really long time and they
start at half the price
of other premium audio brands but they
sound just as good
and raycons come with a 45-day happiness
guarantee so you really
can't lose give them a try and you'll
see what i mean create your own
soundtrack
with raycon right now honeydew listeners
can get 15
off their raycon order at buyracon.com
honeydew that's b u y r a y
c o n dot com slash honeydew to save
fifteen percent on raycons buy raycon
dot com slash honeydew
our next sponsor is babel this summer
get the most out of your travels abroad
by learning the language of your
destination with babel it's the number
one selling language learning app
from ordering in restaurants or asking
for directions to gaining a deeper
understanding
of the culture babel makes the whole
process of learning a new language
addictively fun and easy and with
bite-sized lessons you can actually use
in the real world
babel is a can't miss travel essential
look i actually started using babel
before
they even came on board because that's
how good they were i started taking
spanish i went to
uh mexico and wanted to brush up on my
middle school
spanish and uh it's going bueno y'all
it's going bueno all right excellent
take
muy excelente uh and what i really do
like about it is so you'll take your
lesson
and then they'll do reviews of it and
little snapshots of it so it's always
peppering you with
reminding and you and and also it's not
like it's
what would you say i guess it's street
spanish it's common spanish
you're learning like the language of
people talking on the street not walking
up being all
like proper and might i have some tea
you're not doing that [ __ ] all right
so babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go and unlike the infamous language
classes you took in high school middle
school whatever
babel designs their courses with
practical real world conversations in
mind
all right things you'll get to use in
everyday life other language learning
apps use ai for their lessons plans but
babel lessons were created by over 100
language experts and their teaching
method
has been scientifically proven to be
effective with babel you can choose from
14 different language including spanish
french italian and german and plus babel
speech recognition technology helps you
improve
your pronunciation and your accent all
right
there are so many ways to learn with
babylon additional lessons you can
access
podcasts games videos stories and even
live classes alright so
right now when you purchase a
three-month babel subscription you'll
get an additional three months
for free that's six months for the price
of three just go to babel.com and use
promo code honeydew that's ba
bbel.com code honeydew for an
extra three months free now
let's get back to the duke so i think
like i had been in therapy but it was
like
casual wasn't like anything serious and
then uh
yeah so then i meet i called i called
bob is his name i called bob and i said
hey uh this is
sam you know i guess no way to say your
biological
son this is your first contact yeah yeah
and apparently he told me later he's
like i was on the crapper when you
called
it was just like he's taking it got a
cigarette in his mouth
but he you know here's what she named
i would have gone with something a
little cooler but uh sam
fine well he knew my name because she
saw him on the street once like a long
like when i was like a baby she was
pushing me in the street oh come on
new york can you ima i know so i'm
saying can you imagine being your mom
and this stranger comes by and while
you're pushing his child like [ __ ]
yeah you know i feel for my mom you know
i think she's been through stuff you
know and uh
and then yeah so she's run into him and
he just was like all right he wasn't
very warm
so he she just said this is your this is
sam and he just goes looks like you and
walked away
like he's not he's got a side to him
that's like
all right oh [ __ ] yeah so i heard that i
was like well he's probably not like the
best
person you know i don't like yeah now
that i know him he's not a bad person
he's just he's just not a good bad
dad yeah they're different there is a
difference there are friends of mine who
i'm like
you're a great dude it's not it doesn't
mean you're a great dad
or husband husband exactly i mean look
my mom was a shitty mom
okay but she's got a lot of friends yeah
so she's probably a good friend
but that just because you're one good
thing there people
don't i love that you're saying this
because people don't get this we play so
many roles in our lives father
cousin bro whatever the [ __ ] it is
you're not batting a thousand at all
though
you're just exactly you're just not you
can't so
someone that might think you're a shitty
aunt you might be a great mom
and a great teacher but you could still
be a shitty audience
you're not you're not going to be
perfect true words have never been
spoken and you're a step dad i mean so i
respect people who decide to take
because that's no one's
blueprint no one is like going through
life like someday i'm going to raise
someone else's kid
no one no one is planning on that so i
respect people who do that
you know but so
i have so much love for my dad you know
and and uh
it was you know so i meet bob i meet him
like somewhere
to meet you it's like a coffee shop type
place like a little like a diner-ish
cafe-ish place and uh
and i remember it was both of us he
looks exactly like that and i've never
had that is he tall like you
yeah he's tall um we my grandfather
looked a little bit like me my uncle
looks a little bit like me with my but
he looked i'm like oh [ __ ] this is weird
when you say grandfather and uncle those
so you never knew his p
nothing i didn't know his side no
nothing at all i do a little bit now i
know like you know his parents
are they gone they're gone if they were
alive i'd be like that's 33 i don't want
to meet you this is going to be [ __ ]
weird yeah
but yeah i met him there and yeah
it was so weird that met his uh his wife
is really cool his wife
hold on yeah you walk in yeah yeah are
you there first or is he there first
he was there first do you hug or do you
shake hands or neither i think it was
like a wave it was like
yeah i mean a hug is weird i'm just
asking yeah
he gave me a hug at the end yeah
but so you wave and you sit down it's
just him and you
yeah okay and what's the first do you
remember the first thing he says to you
i think he was just like wow because he
because he was like you look
a lot like he even he couldn't deny it
yeah yeah yeah
and what was what did he say i may try
to early in the year
that doesn't look like me no uh
looks like you i gotta think of [ __ ]
yeah so i think what do you talk about
he just like kind of asked who i was i
think and i asked who he was and like i
didn't know anything about him i was
like what did you do for work and what
yeah like what kind of person what did
you do he worked in advertising
okay yeah um
[Music]
so yeah i think i just he just wanted to
know
he's like what did i miss i'm like well
catch me
i got a time for a cup of coffee can you
wrap up the last two decades
kind of right i mean that's that was
kind of the vibe of it and then
so he goes well i live right by here do
you want to just come up for a minute
and and meet my wife and i said
all right his wife is very much
like you would like her she's very much
in entertainment she
she toured with cher she was a sheriff's
uh
hair stylist she was lily tomlin's hair
stylist
come on so she's like she's like best
friends with lily tomlin who i [ __ ]
love
yeah like who doesn't love lily yeah
she's a genius you know
so and she's got ra music and comedy
deep roots huh
crazy so she gets so she would be like
uh is years ago she'd be like oh i know
a lot of comics because
of the road like comics would open for
sure do you know like dom herrera i'd be
like
tomorrow yeah i'm like that guy's
the best like what do you mean so
yeah it was pretty cool and uh
she was like what she was more like this
is insane
and it's one of those things where it's
hitting her it's hitting her hard where
she's like the
look is weird and uh
it's one of the things you just you
don't realize you're bottling
stuff up until that happens you also
don't even realize
what you have bottled up until at all
for sure when that cork pops you don't
know what the [ __ ] coming out
that's so true it's because it's it's an
unknown so you it does it just hits you
it wants you like oh that's weird
and i remember she uh the girl was
dating the time came by too
and he would come to shows sometimes he
would come to comedy shows he's my show
after you meet him yeah he starts having
a bit of a we had a bit of a
relationship but tell me he
he lived in a neighborhood how close
were you to this coffee shop
geez i mean i was living with my folks
at the time i was probably a couple
miles away
so you're by a lot this is i'm telling
you this is even on the patreon
yeah i have so many guests my myself
included my mom
left the family she moved a mile and a
half down the road
jay larson's dad moved a neighborhood
over
yeah and i'm saying like if you're gonna
leave your [ __ ] family
get out of the zip code so we don't you
know i'm running into another
target and [ __ ] you know what i mean
like why don't we gotta see he's like
that's how good manhattan is you're like
i'm not i want to stay it's got
everything you know
this is my neighbor i was here first my
friend damian lemon who's really funny
he used to have a bit about he's like i
had the type of dad that would leave the
family but stay in the neighborhood so
basically
what you're saying yeah i mean this kid
i had on patreon his biological father
ended up living he's like he lived on my
street i would drive we drive past this
house
every day uh i ca so many people so many
people say
they left the family but they didn't
leave the [ __ ] neighborhood it's so
weird
it is you know we uh it's weird a thing
in therapy too i felt bad
like even complain about it because i
had
a good childhood in a lot of ways i a
lot of ways it was a really great
childhood
and i you know i loving family so it
felt weird
he's like you make any excuse this is
what my therapist said you make any
excuse
to avoid feeling anything and i was like
that's not true and then i took a
martini
like what are you talking about what are
you talking about no i uh
but i he's got a point probably he's got
a point probably but also
the whole point of of therapy too is to
deal with the [ __ ] and then look at the
positive you
already were looking at the positive you
just hadn't dealt with the dog [ __ ] yeah
but
but also you know
you you said it it's interesting because
you only knew your stepdad
yeah and that it how do you it it it's
got to feel
like your father he is my dad i just
call him i mean i was so young i didn't
know
anything i think that's part of the
reason i never wanted to deal with it
because i just knew it wouldn't feel
great like those people
he said go ahead go ahead and dig into
that [ __ ] my friend joe derosa has this
bit weird
you know the other bit i'm talking about
where he said you know he's adopted and
people say you ever try to
meet your real parents and he goes uh no
i took the hint actually
just like i said is there like a better
short joke
jesus christ oh [ __ ] that's like perfect
that's kind of how i felt
that at all but that's kind of how i
felt was like
i know it's not like it's not like he's
gonna you're gonna show up and you're
like oh this guy is a [ __ ] perfect
guy
hey so so all right so you have this
meeting you go up you meet his wife and
now are you texting talking yeah we talk
every once in a while he would call
or no yeah we we would
meet a little more it was more and how
does your mom feel about
all that she's over she's supportive as
she can be i don't think she thrilled i
i don't think it's like oh great you're
meeting
this dude who i have an opinion of
you're not gonna get an unbiased take
yeah so yeah i don't think she loved
that i would try to not bring it up and
then she would casually like oh do you
talk just curious do you talk to him
and i say yeah a little bit did did they
ever
see each other at one of your shows no i
made sure that never happened yeah
i would say he would definitely tell you
mom gets first pick on the show you're
not if she's coming
you can't come you know so
uh but they're not i mean that
he didn't come to like that he came to a
couple shows uh he brought his nephews
to a couple he brought him to a show
once i think it was me and chris d
opening for daryl hammond like a long
time ago at caroline's
and then he came to see it yeah and uh
so i mean we would we wouldn't i don't
talk to him as much now it got harder
you know he has some
mental issues so it got he had a bit of
a depressive
uh breakdown so it became harder to talk
to him and then i was kind of like
the irony of me having to come take care
of him is not lost on me so
i i that became difficult
uh and where are you now with it well
i'm
i think i'm still kind of figuring it
out he lives like nine blocks from me so
that's when it becomes
i would see him on the street and be
like you would wish right now yeah i'd
have to like take a different path
that's my dad yeah i can't do this right
now so i would walk
i didn't consider him my dad though he's
just some dude but that's even weirder
like that's some dude that just looks
like me
how do i introduce them to people yeah i
said ah this is bob and they just look
at both of us and i'd be like
just call him bob all right but i
remember seeing we i saw him at the rec
center once i would i have a lot of bits
about the rec center because i always
just would swim laps at the rec center
and he would just be there
doing physical therapy so it was one of
the things she'd be like hey and you'd
be like hey
it was like it's crazy doesn't that
[ __ ]
i know i know when you walk through it
in the middle of the day
yeah and you just deal with it it feels
normal but at the end of the day when
you really
is that is [ __ ] nuts that's a father
and son
yeah hey hey and don't even really
yeah man it's weird do have you ever
done material
about him when he's been in the office
yeah and how does he take that
he laughs you see he'll say he says in
like a very shitty
i did leave i didn't even know what he
called you saying
he would say like uh he'll say it like
this okay boy you gave me a good
roasting in there
that's how he puts it and what all right
it doesn't even fade one of my first
jokes about something about like how i
was
i was like 19 or 20 when i had this bit
it was like uh yeah i met my biological
father in a in
a coffee shop and it was something along
the lines of like uh
i'm like it was we met it was like a
restaurant it was it was like i say it
was like a
family-style restaurant the joe was like
they should make broken family-style
restaurants
they just walk in like where's the
waiter i think this guy just left
you know that was kind of the premise of
it but it was like
uh yeah but he thought it was funny it
was like that's good
but then uh but it's tough because it
was i definitely had some anger where
it's like you at first you're like this
is great and then you're like oh i have
a little bit of anger here i'm sure and
then you
you deal with stuff in therapy where
you're like i do have issues
with abandonment like a lot of people do
i also have issues but it's like also i
feel
dumb even like who who's like oh cool i
was abandoned you know yeah who likes
being a
nobody's rallying around that cry but
then i also have issues feeling
smothered because my mom was
for a certain so it's weird that those
kind of coincide
yeah you know all right i there's so
much i want to talk to you about i want
to get to
can we switch gears sure uh uh this
weird
uh sex setup you were telling me about
oh yeah
a few stories that are i went this
happened like eight or nine years ago i
went on a date with a girl i just had a
breakup i met her on
some app it was probably tinder or
something and i remember seeing her
picture and she looked
good in the picture but then i see her
she looked even better which is like
when the hell does that happen
yeah ever so we've met this date uh
we went to a bar in brooklyn and she
i got drunk i was gonna say we got drunk
but it was me i was [ __ ] drunk
and uh at the end of the day i remember
i like i she was so proper i remember i
kissed her and
as she like pulled away uh she goes oh
my
i didn't expect that and i was i was
drunk so i was like you better [ __ ]
expect this
and i just never she didn't contact me
ever again
which is like you know it's fine like it
hap i think i text her like once or
twice
and uh she didn't message me and then um
just one afternoon months later on a
friday she texts me like where are you
i said uh i'm in union square in new
york what's up and she writes i want to
see you and i want to get freaky with
you
and i remember writing back oh yeah with
a question mark like what do you
i don't know what the [ __ ] to say to
that it's not like a everyday text i get
and then she writes do you want to get
your dick sucked or not uh
yeah so i was at lunch with my parents
at the time i excused myself obviously
yeah i'm not
i'm not i
but you know what it was i it felt she
was so proper on the date it felt out of
character so i remember i called her and
i was like
expecting it to be some dude stole her
phone sure yeah he's gonna rob me i was
like
hey what's up but she's like look i had
a bad week at work i want to see you
and i want to [ __ ] you and i was like
all right so i go back
to the table with my mom i remember i
was with uh
rachel feinstein earlier today one of my
best friends really funny comic and she
like she's like a sister to me so i i
this is what happens i'm just setting
that up now but
i tell my mom i i said mom i have to
leave this audition just came up
and uh yeah it's like [ __ ] i i don't
lie to my mom so i feel shitty i felt
even
shittier when she was like go get him
sam i was like
i oh like this is well my parents are
like good luck have a good audition
cheer and you want to get your dick
sucked yeah i know i felt so low and
then i remember calling rachel because i
was like hey just a heads up
i'm going to this weird address i'm
gonna like hook up with this girl but
like smart
it's just like it's a different
apartment than when i dropped her often
and it's you know it's just i know
people sublet in new york but it felt
shady to me and rachel was like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you like
you're an idiot you're why do guys do
[ __ ] like this and i was like
testosterone
yeah i'm like are you gonna judge me
you're gonna just take theater she's
like fine
i hear you so then i uh i go to the
place
and i have nerves because it's in the
afternoon and i said hey just meet me
downstairs for a drink
and she comes downstairs and she goes
just come up i have alcohol upstairs and
i said i just feel better if we go to
the bar it's a
it's like a luxury apartment in
williamsburg it's a different place i'm
like this is
weird but then we go up to the apartment
and
the only thing in the apartment is a
couch and a bottle of scotch
so i'm like this looks like a porno set
this doesn't look yeah
right and then she pours me a scotch
down and she pulls me another scotch i
start sipping on it we start making out
she starts going down on me and then she
just stops and she goes
i sure hope my roommate doesn't catch us
and i was like
yeah i also hope your roommate doesn't
catch is it a guy or
yeah exactly i'm like let's i said let's
go to your bedroom and she goes
no i want him to catch us so that's when
i found out
uh dude and like obviously this is the
time you leave
but it's like i'm an idiot i was just
like all right what
you know you listen to your dick you're
like yeah i'm dick's your dick's being
smothered right now i can't
i can't even hear it my dick's like dude
you know i have abandonment issues come
on
don't leave me not right now bro not
right now so i i said all right so we
i'm not your dad i've been here since
day one
[Laughter]
dude i go to i go to a bedroom she
starts
going down to me again and like it's
probably less than a minute the door
just opens and it's a guy
and he's in a tank top he's all tatted
up
he has a cast on one of his arms which
i'm just like what the [ __ ]
like i i don't know why i remember the
cats but it's like it's because that's
the thing that could knock you out if he
hit you
exactly yeah that was one and also i was
just like this looks
weird like i don't know what the hell
happened and she's going down to me and
i just like
i just kind of panic and turn him and i
go can i help you
she's going down to me still i say can i
help you to this guy and he just goes
are we gonna do this
and i was like oh my god uh i said i
don't
i think there's been a misunderstanding
and he goes we so i'm [ __ ] terrified
i'm like i don't know i'm a picture i'm
like having images of
him just like beating me with a hammer
or something and my mom having to
identify the body with my pants down
you know and uh he's just like are you
in you're out and i was like dude what
the [ __ ]
under your [ __ ] girlfriend's mouth
right now bro
i'll be out of here in a minute exactly
like they're dating right i don't i
still haven't pieced this together
he's like are you into your ad i'm like
is this ocean's 11 i'm [ __ ] out what
do you mean am i in
my app so i was like i'm not i just kind
of said this is i'm not this type of
person and he goes
well the door's that way and i kind of
look at her to be like
what the hell like what have you done
and she just kind of shrugged
like not said nothing just shrugged
and i'm like all right i'm freaked out
so i'm i'm thinking like am i gonna get
robbed like what the hell is
this setup uh i i don't even pull my
pants all the way up i remember i had a
backpack i just like waddle over to the
backpack i put it around i was like all
right i'm leaving
and uh down the hallway
yeah and then i'm like i'm like i'm in
the hallway
like looking over my shoulder grateful
that i'm okay
but also like what that's humiliating
i'm i'm so confused i don't know like
was that videotape what the hell
happened
yeah that's a good point so i go into
the uh
i go into the uh elevator i go
downstairs i start walking around the
park in brooklyn i'm like feeling so
[ __ ] low about myself
and i kid you not uh i call rachel first
and she's like i'm glad you're okay i'm
not mad at you
you're just a [ __ ] idiot and i was
like that's fair i deserve that
after i talked to rachel my mom calls to
see how the audition went
how'd it go more people went out for the
part that anticipated
uh no but it's it was brutal
i told this story on something that my
mom heard once and my mom asked me is
this
a true story and i was like i could lie
to you
but i you know i love you yeah it's true
but
you know i made it funny i hope you know
when you heard it and she goes
yeah it upsets me that that's true but
i'm glad that you have that ability to
like
yeah you know make it funny but
[ __ ] yeah that is [ __ ] it was weird
and i remember
i told this to a couple friends this is
all you have to know about comics i told
this to a couple friends at caroline's
i think like the next night and one of
my friends goes i would have [ __ ] both
of them dude
that's all you have to know about every
comedian like whatever like
it's like the most tame story to any
comic you're just like well to me it was
a little traumatizing it's true
it is man to think like also imagine
being that guy
you're okay with your girl bring in any
human being off the [ __ ] street and
walk in
and see me sucking this guy's dick and
then you're gonna come in and [ __ ]
[ __ ] us i don't know yeah exactly i
don't know if there was like where is he
coming from she goes get off work like
where are you coming from bro where are
you coming from right now well he was
there the whole time he was high
oh he was so that's why i was scared he
was like there the whole time
but then also you're right like what's
the what's the procedure is she like
going through photos he's like i'm okay
with this dude
but yeah uh a lot of
and i kind of text her after like what
the hell and she goes sorry thought
you'd be into that i'm like
just on a [ __ ] chance you're going to
assume
like if i did that to a woman i'd be me
too at a [ __ ] show business
but this is just okay to put me through
it yeah
there would definitely be charges there
would be charges
there's no doubt because i have a dick i
don't feel shame and terrified and
that's [ __ ] i mean it's ridiculous
like i had some trust issues on first
dates afterwards
i was definitely like looking i was
definitely looking forward to this
public place
yeah i'd be like why are you looking at
my shower
like the way a little kid looks under
his bed for a boogie man i'm like let me
just make sure
they thinking you're weird
[Laughter]
yeah that was a weird one let's take a
quick break and tell you about our next
sponsor mint mobile
after years of fine print contracts and
getting ripped off by big wireless
providers
if we learned anything it's that there's
always a catch so
when i first heard mint mobile offers
premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month i
thought what's the catch
but after speaking with them it all made
sense all right
mobile secret sauce is that the fir
they're the first company to sell
wireless service
online only so by cutting out the retail
stores
there's no crazy overhead costs that get
passed down to you in the form of
mystery fees instead
mint just passes on sweet savings direct
to you so for people looking for extra
savings
mint mobile offers premium wireless for
just 15 bucks a month
all plans come with unlimited talk and
text and high-speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5g
network so
you're using your own phone with any
mint mobile plan and you can keep your
same phone number
along with your existing contacts and if
you're not 100
satisfied mint mobile has you covered
with their seven day money-back
guarantee okay
you can switch to mit mobile and get
premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mimpmobile.com
honeydew that's mintmobile.com
honeydew cut your wireless bill to 15
bucks a month
at mintmobile.com honeydew
our next sponsor is green chef green
chef lets you choose from a wide array
of easy to follow recipes perfect for
keto
paleo and plant-powered diets or even if
you just want to eat in a more balanced
way
green chef's expert chefs design
flavorful recipes that go way beyond
ordinary for a diverse array of meal
plans
and plenty of options to choose from
each week look i've been getting them
delivered to me
i get so many different options they're
they're easy to make the recipes are
simple
the ingredients are all right there
stella helps me out with it i'm like
give me a little bit of that
that bang bang bang we try it out and
they're really good meals they're
healthy they're uh delicious and it's
nice to come home
and have something like that instead of
just eating fast food on the way home
from the comedy store or something you
know
so here's what you got to do all right
go to greenchef.com
honeydew100 and use code honeydew100 to
get 100
off including free shipping all right
it's again green chef dot com
slash honeydew 100 and use code honeydew
100 to get a hundred bucks
off including free shipping that's a
hell of a deal y'all
they are the number one meal kit for
eating well
now let's get back to the duke um all
right well you have another weird story
i want to talk about something you
witnessed
that uh i really want to hear about
because i know we've had
nob i don't think we've had anybody tell
a story like this i've talked about that
one before
i've never talked about this one i don't
think on a podcast or anything and
so what happened was i was probably in
sixth grade and
i was walking to the bus stop with my
friend new york city and
i remember just stopping you have that
student metro card in new york so i
remember stopping going hey man
um let me just stop uh to get my metro
card out and right as i say that
splat a woman jumped out of a building
to her death suicide you know splat
i was the closest person on the street
to her 7 20 30 feet
i want to go like 8 to 10 feet away did
you get any splat on you dude
no that was what was weird is movies lie
about that [ __ ] there's not that much
blood
what was really [ __ ] up is she wasn't
immediately dead no
that was what was how high up do you
know stories or more
probably more holy [ __ ] yeah she wanted
she was an old woman
she clearly wanted to die but the fact
that she was i think
all i remember was she goes i'm cold and
uh she was speaking she mumbled i'm cold
someone heard that
and they walked over with a blanket for
you ain't gonna have to worry about that
a couple more seconds probably gonna be
a brutal for you brutal
dude you could have died i know i think
about this sometimes and i remember
this table's six feet long two more feet
that's how close this is if i didn't
stop to get my metro card outside
right i remember uh you had a near-death
experience because someone was taking
their own [ __ ] life
i know that's crazy i remember thinking
later like
angry for a minute like you couldn't
have done pills or blown your head off
or something like what the hell
uh but she went splat and i mean she's
down
how did she fall do you see it all in
your head yeah
she went like head first or flat are we
talking about flat pancake down pancake
face down
yeah face down pants nothing not not a
gory bloody side no it wasn't
just like every bone probably turned to
dust in her body probably and she said
i'm cold
that's what she said to someone yeah
that was it
yeah she was mumbling how long were you
did you leave after that
and then i was pretty freaked out and my
friend and i got into a cab and we
and we bolted but uh i remember uh
a people a couple people from my school
call because they were like who was
there and
and you know this teacher i was like mr
jones he was the best dude he was like
he died a few years ago he was such a
cool teacher he was uh
he was like the type of teacher he was
like an old gay man and he just like
he was just the best i remember i got in
trouble for this is so stupid i did i
can't believe i'm admitting this but i
used to
my friend uh my friend's dad had like
you know color print or whatever we just
printed out nudes
on there and we sold it as a magazine in
school to other sixth graders
entrepreneur man called play amigo
magazine
and uh and he found it and he goes he
looked at it and and he goes
i'm just he's an old gay man he's like
i'm just gonna say that you were selling
that you were looking at sears
catalogues and i was just like ah he's
the best
so he could have gotten me in trouble
and he's like you're fine but he called
and he's like i just wanna make sure
you're okay i'm like i'm okay yeah yeah
and then uh i called i had a kid i was
pretty good friends with whose mom was
like kind of nuts and she uh
like if she picked up the phone you were
gonna hear 20 minutes from her
almost like a sixth grader yeah you know
like she was the type of mom where she
was uh she's always really nice to me
but she would like just get new pets
like she'd be like well this pet's not
cute anymore i'm gonna give it up for
adoption
like completely nuts like she'd be like
i'd be like what happened to that dog
you had she's like i grew up and it's
like what
it's like two years old dude there was
always a new kitten and i'm like these
are the cutest animals i've ever seen
but you can't just like get rid of
you know so anyway uh i call him to like
check
just be telling what happened and she
picked up the phone and it was like
her just talking at me for like 20
minutes she's like and then this
happened and then also another thing
she's like how was your day i was like
i just saw someone die and she was like
oh well elliot's not home right now and
i was like jesus
blew right through it just blew through
it yeah just uh do you remember the
sound
yeah it was it was like a thud it was it
was loud you can you compare it to
anything
like what if you say this the mind
protects you in a weird way so i
remember when i first saw it i was like
is this punk i remember thinking like am
i on like a hidden camera show because
you're just like oh maybe they're
filming a movie or something body just
be falling out of the sky
you make excuses so i was like maybe
they're filming uh
some sort of uh movie that they just
didn't i stumbled onto a set
you know in midtown manhattan i don't
know why but uh
yeah i remember it it doesn't compute
immediately it takes you a second to
realize
because you're like why would this
happen in front of me or this close to
me
when it's that close you're just like
what if that lady hits you
yeah is it a murder suicide would that
be a murder so
i don't think there's going to be anyone
to try but yeah
you'd have to classify that i think
you're right [ __ ] yeah
it's a murder-suicide yeah have you ever
seen it since then have you ever that's
your
obviously probably your first dead body
right yeah you ever seen another one
since
you see in new york you just see
ambulances everywhere so you see people
getting loaded and you're like that
guy's not doing well but that was the
first like just
death i've seen for sure yeah that's
that's crazy to witness that
yeah [ __ ] yeah it wasn't it's weird i ha
it would pop into dreams every once in a
while because heights is such a
i i'm scared of heights to begin with i
am now i wasn't before
yeah what happened my daughter almost
got hit by a car what
and it rattled me and it unearthed
[ __ ] anxiety that had been laying
just
just kicking back waiting for something
to bring it up and
boom it did and all of a sudden i got
scared to fly
and i got scared of heights and not the
same like when i look out a plane window
to me that looks cartoonish that does i
don't fear that but
like a realistic height like i wouldn't
live in a high rise in new york city
really
have a balcony and walk out no i
couldn't do it yeah
too but one but before that it never
it's like having a gun
yeah having a i feel way safer having a
gun
i would have 20 guns in my home before
i'd live on a
on a 40th story if you get suicidal or
something or something
you know what i mean that's that's what
a bit like yeah uh i'm with you the
balcony freaks me out no i can't
i can't scare them we were in um i was
just talking about this with segura we
were in this
um it was a couple years ago it was a
vegas festival
and they had all of us up in this really
nice place did this go bankrupt this
festival
i think it did yeah yeah and it i
remember this
they had a balcony and like 10 people
were out there on it and i remember
walking out and it was up there and
first of all the
the height got me nervous and i was like
you know and then i'm like this is gonna
[ __ ]
it's gonna snap i feel like the weight
of all you people on this is not it's
for a family normally it's not for a
party of 20
out here and i just couldn't i was like
i just i was like excuse me excuse me
excuse me i went right back at that
[ __ ] thing i'm like y'all can party
out here all you want
i'm with you i'm totally i hate when
people you ever have that person when
you're on like a high
on something some high level and they're
just like kind of like joking around
dangling off i'm like that's not a
[ __ ] good j
i don't like jokes that are just like
that someone might die
yeah yeah that's not my type of humor
that [ __ ] we were kids
we'd buy the cheap seats in the upper
deck at 33rd street to go see the
orioles and
you know that those old stadiums were
like this and we we'd be sliding by
might they go oh
he'd always do that like stop god damn
it stop doing that [ __ ] man it's so
scary it's a horrible joke
also that's like don't do it if it's the
way people actually die like that used
to be a news story like
they fought over the rail like oh a
deranged fan fell off and uh you know
yeah yeah brutal what um did that start
your
fear of heights did you do you remember
having one
i definitely was like that was the
moment i was like oh you could die
randomly that was the thing i i thought
like
so it just gave me a like a fear of
death i think
yeah which is like probably why i try to
put out as much material as possible
because i could just die
in a random way uh so that was one thing
uh and then you said you did dream about
it once in a while yeah i would have
dreams of like
people splattering me oh oh actually
hitting you yeah yeah oh whoa
yeah and you would see that in your
dreams yeah and i'd be like all smushed
man i don't know if i've i always
thought they say if you see yourself die
in your dreams you really die i don't
know if i've ever seen myself really
maybe i didn't die i just remember the
just them crushing you crushing me yeah
yeah or like
maybe i woke up before she even hit me i
remember just seeing that woman
and is it still that was it that lady
every time like what you remember seeing
do you remember what she was wearing it
was so long i was so young when i had it
she i remember it was like a gown
it looked like some sort of gown and
it's morning you're on your way to
school
or is it coming home coming home oh [ __ ]
yeah i remember i got out of a test the
next day and i was like man i'm so lucky
and now i look back i'm like oh maybe i
should have taken that test
i remember being like i'm like man i
[ __ ] i don't have to take a test i
didn't study for
they were like you shouldn't have to
take and i was like that's what trips me
out about life is like the seconds that
can actually matter if
you what was it you stopped to look for
what again
from the metro card that's why part of
it yeah if you don't stop
boom if you take that test you know you
get a light on any other corner
you don't [ __ ] see that well you see
you're dead you don't see it almost hit
you it's funny isn't that crazy
yeah i also think that's what us why
it's so important the timings everything
then you also have that thought where
you're like man that's kind of a selfish
way to kill yourself
to jump out onto a crowded street but
also then i was all i go back and forth
i'm like well she's not thinking in the
right place
she's not thinking in the right mind to
take her own life so then it's also hard
to
actually be upset like she's [ __ ]
dead so
you know that's yeah i knew another kid
who
jumped out of a i knew a kid who jumped
out of a 30-story window and killed
himself yeah when i was in like
30 stories yeah in new york yeah that's
what i'm talking about i would never
even live up there
it's sooner or later it calls you to
come out of those
that calls the void like what are you a
[ __ ]
sam jump you'll be fine yeah how old was
he
ninth grade or something oh he was young
maybe tenth grade and i was in eighth
grade maybe that's how it was and it was
suicide it wasn't an accident or maybe i
was 9th and he was in 11th
uh he
yeah i think was suicide he was like a
depressed kid
30 he was always doing drugs he was like
that kid at the party he always saw
blowing lines and [ __ ] but he was like
way too young for that [ __ ]
and he was just like a nice guy he was
just like a nice [ __ ] up guy but uh
yeah i remember that was when i was like
oh i should probably not
uh that was my first thing i probably
should not do hard drugs because he was
always doing them and i was like he's
[ __ ] up
but um i remember at the funeral there
were people doing blow and i'm like
it's like the worst [ __ ] people real
yeah
yeah that's uh yeah god damn
all right let's switch gears all right
we we've been down enough let's talk you
got two stories i want here i want to
hear a latrell spree well
okay i want to hear pittsburgh morning
tv story
okay i'll do which one should we do
first let's do the trail
he was my favorite knicks growing up
such a big basketball fan i love starks
i love viewing oak mace
but that's patrick ewing adidas back in
the day
yeah he was just special i loved them
but uh
yeah then that next team that older team
i love dell j i love spree
i really love spreewell and i mean that
guy his whole career was insane he
choked his coach
she did pj carlos portland then right
golden state all golden state choked his
coach and
the knicks picked him up which are like
okay i mean
i'll take it i know he's a great player
and he was awesome like he couldn't it's
like crazy
that a guy does that and then he shows
up to a huge market
and you know exceeds expectations so i
loved him
and then i'm doing a gig in baltimore
years ago and
um i get off stage i'm
in a nick sweatshirt i love the knicks i
love basketball but
the host goes you should go drink at
that bar with us because we're
uh we go there all the time and
spreewall's there every night in
milwaukee's from milwaukee
and i said uh uh he's not gonna be there
and like every
like he's [ __ ] kenny powers he's just
like you know getting lit up he's a
hometown hero there
and we're there and he's not gonna come
he comes in he walks in he's got dyed
red hair
uh he's in a sweatsuit he's a big dude
he's noticeable
he's at the bar and someone whispers to
me he drinks honey jack
and i'm like ooh all right so i go over
to him and i was like
oh man i'm such a big fan of yours i
never do this [ __ ] but i was like
an idiot i was young you know and i and
i said and he goes okay
and i'm just like uh can i get you a
drink he goes i already have a drink
and i was like i'm like think what what
card can i play yeah so i panicked and i
was like
i'm a comedian i'm playing the club next
door you should come to a show
uh this weekend he goes don't count on
it
that's good writing though it's brutal
and and then i i said
all right so i feel it inside right now
it hurts i go back to the end of the bar
and then she
uh we're with a few other people and one
of them works for bleach report he goes
i'll handle this and he walks over and
we just see spree like
you go losing at him i was like i got
off easy all right [ __ ]
so uh whatever we watch him be kind of
rude to a bunch of other people he's not
really having it maybe just wants to
drink alone whatever
a couple nights later the bartender from
the
from the bar you know she's at my show
and she starts talking to me afterwards
she goes
you know he can be tough but he's really
a sweetheart and i was like
all right whatever and she texts him
look i'll show you
uh i'm at the comedian who uh who you
met that bar
the other night i'm at his show and she
goes oh yeah great guy that's rewrites
back
i was like that's how he treats someone
he thinks a great guy
she's like he's just not he's not warm
but he's a good guy and i was like
i think he just likes his bartender
anyway years later
years later i had a sports show on msg
and i had he was he was
he was pretty nice he was i didn't
mention this story i was gonna
i didn't i was going to but here's what
happened he was he was
so i would do a cold open thing with any
athlete or actor that came on the show
or
the joke would be they just didn't want
to be there but they would do it in
different ways like i'd have like
cece sabbath he would be sitting there
and he i'd be like oh dude i'm so happy
to have you he's like are you kidding
it's my favorite show in the back really
be like no
you can't it's like the show stinks like
and athletes would always they
were down they were down to like be
funny and i asked spree i'm like hey it
may be funny if you're like you're just
texting
and i keep asking you uh you know i keep
saying like hey you know
i keep asking you questions you keep
going uh-huh and you just keep nagging
me
and he was like no i'm not doing that he
was the only person to say that so i was
kind of like
i already feel like we got it in real
life but not all games i'm not doing a
character
i'm not doing me in real life well i
think that's what
he was known as having a hard edge where
these other guys weren't so if he does
that on the show maybe
i get why now but in the moment i was
like i don't wanna
i don't wanna be choked yeah i don't i
don't wanna like
piss him off twice so i was kind of like
so i mean you were you know
99 finals i'm just like trying to get
away from that but
it ended up being like you know i was so
nervous that would end up being not one
of my better
interviews but uh i mean dude he was the
best
even that night after he snubbed me or
whatever i watched clips of him
on the knicks and i was like i still
love the guy what can you do he's the
best
um let's hear about this morning show in
pittsburgh
pittsburgh uh i've never done
i've never had to do morning tv radio
it's fun if you make it a disaster
that's what i'm saying like segora
really figured it out
tracy morgan's the king of the wrecking
mourning team so good
i've never seen tracy morgan but the
segura stuff i've seen is so so
great uh and i've heard about tracy
morgan and then
yeah i would just i'd be like well the
only way i'm gonna move tickets on here
like this isn't exactly my target demo
is people that sincerely watch morning
tv
so i would just try to make it go off
the rail so
also you're on two hours sleep people
don't realize when you're doing these
shows
yes you literally slept for two hours
because you have a night show
then you have to wake up at like six and
then you have two shows that night so
you're just like
i'm on fumes and then also how many of
these shows can you do where they do
no research the questions are so phoned
in where they're just like
so have you always been funny and i'm
just like she asked me that the woman
asked me that and i go
i say no actually i uh i wasn't when i
was young my uncle molested me and he
was funny
and he gave me spider-man like powers
and they just stare at me and they go
okay then i saw this interview now that
you say that
and and as i walk off i see the producer
they're fuming
a couple people laughed their ass off
but i said to one producer i was like
can i get that clip and he goes
absolutely not
don't count all right so don't count on
it
well i say so i so i i'm like i don't
know how to get that that clip is so
damn
perfect how do i get man so i i go on
twitter does anyone
record pittsburgh uh today live or
whatever
and like someone did it wasn't great
quality but we got it and uh
that's what i saw they won't yeah they
won't do
comics online they won't have us anymore
and they're just that you are the last
comment so if you're playing
the pittsburgh improv and you don't have
morning tv you're welcome
but that moved a lot of tickets because
i caught i'm like that's the only way
if i'm doing morning radio and it's like
a sincere radio guy who like i'm like
that it was different than the energy
being like coming up next uh which uh
which
treat goes well with this i'm like i'm
not this is not right
it's so good i love that [ __ ] i love
doing those
i mean to
i remember seeing that you got to go
watch that video
find that clip it's so good i remember
watching it so what did what
after that you walk out and they're just
pissed off they were just like what the
hell was that
i i would cushion it i would try to
build up to those moments so they would
be
like i would try to like answer
everything very sincerely and then sneak
a moment like that in
because that moment would be so
unexpected
so good uh but the hardest part was
keeping a straight face because there
was a moment where you see in the video
where i'm literally right after i say
that i say it and i look
seriously and there's a moment where i
just look at the camera and smile
you could you could see that i was like
this close to breaking
i love it dude i love it but you know
what you're right
[ __ ] them do your job yeah do your
goddamn job can you ask some real
questions you can't go
look me up and ask me any oh we saw a
clip you did about this
exactly nothing if it's sincere
but then you do some where they do do
that and then i'm like well i'm gonna
seriously just try to
kill and just joke for him with like
what i would do at a show or something
but then when you do the ones who are
just like you could tell they don't
respect what you have
always been funny is so [ __ ] like how
much work did you do it's so lazy you
could ask your kids last night i got
this comic come on
what do you what should we ask them yeah
they would have come up with something
better than have you always been funny
it's just
you know what it is it's also them being
like we're gonna do no research or no
work
carry the interview yes so it's like
it's beyond lazy so i'm like all right
i'll do what i want to do if you're
gonna like give me the floor i'm gonna
you know dude i um
i really appreciate you coming on and it
was a ton of fun to be on me
i'm glad you came on and the [ __ ] you
talked about with your dad
so will he come to shows now like will
you see him again
i don't it's been a while he's pretty
old i mean
you said he also had this mental thing
yeah to
break down am i great the one thing i
might inherit from you is uh
that's the other thing do you have any
genetic [ __ ] you got to worry about
probably i mean i'm sure is his wife
still with him
yeah the lady you met and she's still
cool with you too yeah she's really
she's really cool
she's taking care of him or whatever
she's very cool um
but yeah i'm sure i mean
i guess other than that he's in decent
health you know
but that's that's a rough one i mean i'm
like hey [ __ ] the one thing we need is
our minds in this uh
in this field you know so but he's in
his 80s now you said
like 86 probably that's up there maybe
maybe more yeah
um this is your first time here on the
show and i ask everybody their first
time on advice you would give to your
sick
after everything we've talked about
advice you would give to your 16 year
old self
probably just like don't worry so much
like
it's it's things are gonna happen or
they're not you are you a big warrior my
mom is the biggest warrior of anyone
i've ever met in my life like i she
always thinks it's like she's like oh
i'm glad i'm she
she sounds like olivia soprano when i
when i make fun of her when she's just
like oh i guess i'm just a big
joke around here but i i love my mom but
she worry
i mean like i get it i'm her only
biological kid she but she worried i
think before that she's a warrior she's
just like
she'll admit she's like i worry a ton uh
i mean i literally have a bit about
me walking with her and seeing a dead
pigeon i go look and my mom goes don't
touch it
like you're gonna brush what what do you
think i'm gonna do so i mean that's
that's her energy uh is is just constant
worry and
uh so yeah it does make me
a little more anxious and uh
yeah but then it's like well look my
girlfriend worries a shitload too i mean
i think i may be attracted to that
because it i take worrying as a sign of
love
and care so maybe that's interesting a
part of it
yeah but yeah i worry because of that
okay but then there's also a part of me
that's like who gives a [ __ ] like
you know like the worrying's covered but
then for a period i think i
when i was 16 i was like oh no like you
think things matter
that don't matter and then you grow up
and you think things matter
again that don't matter that cycle
repeats and then you're like
what really matters is that you surround
yourself with
decent people that's right who make you
feel good and that you make feel good
and just that you don't waste
this [ __ ] you know that you yeah you
have your health and that you don't
waste
you know this go-around i guess you know
to someone choosing
i do this five-minute journal every day
and every [ __ ] day the first thing i
put down
almost 90 percent of time is i'm
grateful for my health
because when i was [ __ ] up like i went
through this whole health scare a few
years ago and it's like
man every day i wake up and i don't have
to worry about
pain injury being sick none of that [ __ ]
like
your health is it's everything it's it's
[ __ ] everywhere even when you have a
bad
cold that first day you feel better
you're like oh my god
yeah yeah and this business is
especially you you said you love the
road so i love it it's a challenge to
stay healthy on the road with all the
garbage they feed you with the easy
easily fast food uh available options
out there
no exercising unless you really [ __ ]
you have to work for those that's right
for those extras oh man i was swimming
at that there was a rec center in
raleigh and i was doing laughs a guy
next to me at a [ __ ] epileptic
seizure while you're in the [ __ ] pool
he got out he was like panicking but
he got out but he's like it looked like
a dying fish on the side of the thing he
was like
it was horrible whoa they had to call an
ambulance yeah i feel so bad for the guy
and the craziest thing is i looked at
him
laying two's open
but i look at the guy right before it
happened i was like that guy's in good
shape
like you never you really you never know
you never know what someone's going
through he was in like better shape than
me so i was like he's in good shape yeah
but he's got epilepsy
so yeah you don't know what you don't
know that's another thing like
16 like i empathy is something i've had
to work on
and it's really since i was a kid it was
hard for me to have empathy and like as
i get older
i do realize that everyone's got [ __ ]
that they don't and sometimes the best
people don't bring that [ __ ] around
because they know because they don't
want to burden anybody right but just
because someone acts happy all the time
doesn't mean they're not
going through [ __ ] so i definitely to
have more empathy for people
is is something i it's something i'm
working on as well but yeah me too
dude this was great um please plug
everything you want again
a lot of i mean i got the two specials
on youtube up on the roof and i got this
uh and then you know two podcasts one's
if you're into basketball you'll love
pod don't lie if you're into just
whatever general stuff so we might be
drunk and uh
yeah i'm on the road constantly so yeah
i mentioned a bunch of dates yeah
uh i'm coming to your city so you know
boston philly
uh your website portland samurai
slash shows all there yeah all right
dude thank you so much pleasure man this
is a lot of fun
uh and as always ryan sickler.com ryan
sickler on all social media we will talk
to you all
next week
[Music]
you